remember when Gweneth Paltrow named her
kid Apple that kids got to be [ __ ] 35
now or some [ __ ]
Apple Paltrow but it was with was
probably Apple Martin no because she did
was it with Chris Martin Apple Martin
sue how old is she now
13 Wow yeah 13 years ago about when
people are like wow they got old as I
get time happens [ __ ]
Oh sue better names Apple huh it's
[ __ ] stupid these are the names you
pick Casey Kent Ralph J Jane Robert
Chris Matt David Dan Rebecca Lisa you
know what you don't name a kid [ __ ]
Audio science well who was that one
Shannyn Sossamon girl girl and boy Audio
science pilot inspector hey that kids
there's no way Audio science and pilot
inspector isn't going to go to Art Basel
when they grow up dude pilot inspector
just the visual of what that is is like
I imagine like somebody [ __ ] like
looking at a pilot like lifting up their
balls and like looking under their
armpits and [ __ ] like okay he's good
pilot inspector how [ __ ] up do you
have to be to name your kid pilot
inspector and if you're if you name your
kid pilot inspector you better wear a
cape every [ __ ] day go for it go for
it [ __ ]
you can't be named you can't be named
your kids [ __ ] like that and and not go
full throttle and just like you can't
naming your kid pilot respect gonna be
like I gotta go to a [ __ ] Best Buy
today and see what I guess I got to get
a cat [ __ ] a SIM card listen look at
these [ __ ] names Moon Unit Zappa put
Ptolemy what these are the names I don't
even know how the poppy honey Rosie
Daisy boo petal blossom these are all
these [ __ ] famous idiots
Fifi Trixie Bell is that the name denim
Col band Italy their way oh those are
dogs well then what the [ __ ] it matter
here we go come on
what was it good you got to go in too
fast kid that's one Nakoa wolf manic
kaupo Nemec a hama MOA oh that's yeah
but that's like some that's like their
culture or some [ __ ] you know yeah like
they got like they he's so Hawaiian dude
have you seen even if he's not Hawaiian
he's [ __ ] wine have you seen that
video on Jason Momoa where he like
produced it and it's all about his life
and [ __ ] and he's just like throwing
axes at [ __ ] trees and [ __ ] and he
and ended playing with his kids and he
was just like talking
it's it's so pretentious I I like Jason
Momoa I'm not I'm not even talking [ __ ]
but that video is just like all
slow-motion and he's tickling his kids
and he's got paint on his pants like a
real guy kids are my life I never knew
what I had until I had kids you know
that kind of a vibe I'm all about work I
like to get my hands dirty it's like
that kind of a thing and you keep
waiting for it to be like oh what's this
a commercial for and then it just ends
and you're like oh he just made this
[ __ ] and it went viral and and
and housewives are just like if I could
only
if I could only sure oh okay all right
here you here we go this is the worst
one I think maybe I mean I don't know if
it's worse than [ __ ] pilot inspector
that may be the worst one ever
but Jermaine Jackson has a lot of kids
okay uh these are all there his name's
okay
germy okay sure Jeremy there you go
Jordan fine but now we're getting a
little iffy cuz it spelled j o u rdy
nn-no naturally you should unabashedly
spell it jo r da and otherwise you
complete piece of [ __ ] but he did it now
granted he did it because he was
molested as a kid that's the thing if
you get molested as a kid you got a more
chance of [ __ ] definitely naming your
kid some [ __ ] up weird [ __ ] and
spelling it in a weird way now granted
lost subscribers by saying that but
gotta keep it real for babies you got to
keep it real for the babies if you get
molested if you get molested you have a
chance if you get molested you have a
higher chance of naming your kid
something weird like [ __ ] moan unit
or spelling Jordan Jo u rdy NN Jafar
Jackson there's one now begin Aladdin
know your cartoon no name um Tom Mecca
and Medinah
alright Mecca no Medina maybe here's the
one though that makes me want to throw
myself down a flight of stairs your
majesty
I mean come on dude jerm a gist e dude
imagine showing up at Applebee's and
being like yeah four please okay what
should I put it under your majesty if I
worked at Applebee's here's where I
would say no give me another name I'll
put it under Phil and you just respond
to Phil here's your [ __ ] ticker when
it buzzes come over here Phil jerm a
gist II do names [ __ ] names that are
where you're like how do you spell it
nah yeah Roger
cool ROG er no no it's spelled r aw Jay
o R no no you know what I'll spell it
ROG er cuz that's raw jor hello I am Raj
our Moon Unit Oh
Nick Nolte's kid Brawley King I don't
even know these names are so [ __ ] up
wait hold on stop it there across his
three marriages John Cougar Mellencamp
has collected a wide array of kids with
head-turning names this is real his name
is kid's name is HUD HUD Teddy Joe
justice but the one that takes the
[ __ ] bitch-ass cake space
wild horse that's his kids name spec
wild horse Wow if I ever meet John
Cougar Mellencamp I'm gonna literally be
like yeah hey what's up I'm Chris hey
what what's the deal what were you
thinking man what's what what's what
were you thinking
and he knows deep down what I'm talking
about
that's how [ __ ] up that name is he
would say what do you mean and I'm
saying you know you know what I mean man
what what's the deal with the whole
thing with why you did that and he'd be
like finally we would get to the point
where he'd be like you talking about why
I named my kid spec wild horse and I'm
like of course why did you do it
and then he would [ __ ] put his head
in his palms eventually and probably
start crying and be like because I
really needed them to go to Art Basel
and that's how the only way I knew that
they would go I needed them to buy rocks
on top of each other I needed them to
buy boulders on cars